technetium is the first element in the
periodic table which is naturally
radioactive so it is the lightest
radioactive element and so for a long
time very little was known about it now
people are beginning to study it in
suitably strong surroundings of to
contain the radioactivity and they have
discovered that the chemistry of
technetium is in many ways quite similar
to that of rhenium or manganese and the
there are a number of medical treatments
now which use the radioactivity of
technetium in order to trace through the
body and look at their emissions to find
out about different diseases and so the
chemistry of technetium is becoming
quite important in the medical role how
to make a compound that you can get into
the body safely and quickly so that it
can be used for medical purposes